orry begins here at a gas station that's
home to several hundred migrants many
came directly from a domain II just
before authorities evacuated the campus
it's a story of hope but even more so
it's a story of desperation the gas
station at if Sony is one of the last
places where refugees are allowed to
live free and without supervision but
it's days are numbered as authorities
plan to evacuate them and so every day
people try their luck to cross the
border into Macedonia illegally Mohamed
nadri from Afghanistan tried eight times
every time the Macedonian police caught
him and brought him back to a hole in
the border fence but he sees no other
way than to try again and again no
there's no hope increase economy it has
a Khanna me Chris right now so there's
no work and there's it's hard to live
here that's why it seems like a game of
hide-and-seek that refugees and police
are playing at the Greek Macedonian
border
across the highway some hide in the
forest a life under revolting conditions
garbage and human waste flies and
mosquitoes next we find an abandoned
house which is now home to three Syrian
families we meet Hamada Bush who tells
us what everybody in evallonia is
talking about at night he'll try to
cross the green border together with his
life and children and he knows Europe
there's little chance they will succeed
Alain de espana and it does we further
down the highway the conditions get even
worse than any domaining again garbage
the stench of feces and people living in
tents in between nobody wants to stay in
a place like this but hardly anyone can
afford 3,000 euros for a smuggler
Muhammad Ahmad from Pakistan tells us
why he thinks he cannot resettle to a
government-run camp the Pakistani
immigrants fairies if we have who don't
have documents record straight we have
to go jail nine months six months 18
months like this then he asks us what we
know about the rumors that police will
evacuate this camp very soon when
suddenly we hear the sound of an
excavator authorities begin tearing down
the shack sat at Sony soon the illegal
makeshift camps in northern Greece will
be history and every day the dream of
reaching north and Europe becomes more
and more distant